es las personas que hacen fila en este
momento que ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas han hecho fila por
aproximadamente 9 horas y todavía les
falta una gran parte para poder llegar
al parlamento al westminster hall para
poder rendir un tributo muy especial a
la reina isabel solo las personas que
están en la fila actualmente podrán
ingresar el gobierno decretó una pausa
de 6 horas así que se espera en las
próximas horas por la tarde pueda
abrirse más personas puedan unirse a
esta fila como lo mencionaba el tiempo
de espera es de aproximadamente 14 horas
y las filas ya alcanzan los 8 kilómetros
pero durante el fin de semana ese tiempo
de espera podría duplicarse o
triplicarse
hemos hablado con las personas que están
haciendo la fila están usando abrigos
gruesos compartiendo té comida y dicen
que esta espera es larga hace frío pero
lo más importante para ellos es puede
rendir este tributo especial a la reina
isabel el gobierno constantemente a
través de las redes sociales está
diciéndoles a las personas en qué punto
podrán unirse de la fila esto cuando sea
reabierta